ici
je suis très heureux d'être aujourd'hui
ici avec vous car c'est à la réunion il
ya déjà quelques années que mon rêve
d'enfant est née à l'époque nous
n'avions pas d'internet
mes parents n'avaient pas les moyens de
m'acheter un billet d'avion pour pouvoir
voyager à l'étranger
heureusement de temps en temps à l'école
nous avions la chance d'avoir des
conférenciers qui venaient nous
présenter les pays et les régions du
monde dans lesquels ils avaient voyagé
c'était une aubaine pour le cancre que
j'étais plus de dicter plus de tables de
multiplication nous n'étions plus des
élèves remonter les uns contre les
autres mais unis le temps d'un voyage
projeté dans la salle de classe et parmi
ces régions du monde
l'himalaya j'avais trouvé l'endroit qui
allait changer ma vie est comme si
conférencier j'allais moi aussi un jour
voyage est le problème
comment faire à 8 ans quand la société
nos parents nous apprennent à rester
prudent à être sages à se préserver pour
plus tard comment atteindre ce rêve cet
himalaya
pour trouver la réponse ils devaient
attendre vingt ans sur youtube en
regardant un documentaire consacré
auteuil train de darjeeling darjeeling
une petite ville située dans l'himalaya
indien et en découvrant ce reportage
j'ai découvert un portrait sita chetrit
7h et riz à un rêve offrir à ses cinq
fils la meilleure des écoles la
meilleure d éducation et pour ça elle
travaille très dur elle fait un métier
d'homme pour le rêve d'une femme si
tâche et report les bagages des
voyageurs qui arrivent par ce petit
train à darjeeling par son rêve à elle
sita chetrit avait réveillé le mien
j'allais quelques mois plus tard de
paris où j'étais installé rejoindre
l'himalaya indien darjeeling pour aller
à sa rencontre
elle venait de me réveiller mon rêve
mais si tu as she tries a également
permis d'ouvrir une nouvelle porte et
qu'elle porte celle de mes origines plus
d'un milliard deux cousins deux cousines
potentiel je suis arrivé en inde
je ne connaissais rien hein je n'étais
jamais venu l'inde dont je porte
pourtant la couleur de peau hâlée
m'apprendre le vivre ensemble
comment se respecter soi et les autres
grâce à l'aide des indiens en m'offrant
un repas en offrant un ticket de train
ou en hébergeant j'ai plus quelques
semaines plus tard arrivée à darjeeling
et rencontrer si tu achèterais bon
maintenant j'ai perdu à l'époque
vous savez en inde les gens vous
nourrissent très bien maintenant j'ai
perdu 14 kilos en dix mois
mais de ce voyage j'en garde
en plus de cette rencontre avec sita
chetrit j'en garde un merveilleux
souvenir celui de tous ces gens qui
étape par étape
mom et varel par un simple sourire une
bouteille d'eau ou un repas en rentrant
un pari j'ai repris mon travail mon
logement la vie qu'on attendait de moi
mais le problème c'est que ce rêve là
que je venais de réaliser cet himalaya
que je venais d'atteindre mon himalaya
celle que les indiens mais venaient de
m'offrir ce rêve était devenu trop gros
pour entrer dans ce petit tiroir dans
lequel plus jeune mes parents m'avaient
dit un jour tu réaliseras ton rêve mais
pour l'instant gare de l'est dans un
tiroir
j'ai donc décidé de reprendre la route
le problème c'est que voyager pour
voyager ça m'ennuie et j'ai donc eu
l'idée à mon tour d'essayer à mon niveau
2 réalisé par mon rêve le rêve d'autres
enfants et d'autres personnes tout comme
sita chetrit et ses conférenciers à
l'école l'avait fait pour moi j'ai donc
travaillé un an pour économiser quelques
sous
j'aimais mon travail à paris j'étais
webb analyste
mais aujourd'hui je laime encore
davantage parce que ce travail est
aujourd'hui au service de mon rêve à
vince est l inverse
une année plus tard je me suis retrouvé
sur la route
ce voyage les appliques de passe sur le
monde j'essaie avec deux pas sur le
monde de voyager le plus gratuitement
possible en stop et en me faisant
héberger
j'ai également une tante qui me permet
de passer des nuits parfois dans des
endroits assez insolite avec l'argent
que je dépense pas mon budget quotidien
est d'environ 10 dollars par jour je
reverse à des associations pour enfants
j'ai quitté paris à dix mois en train
stop tgv stop pour l'italie puis de
l'italie à la turquie en asie centrale à
la mongolie en chine asie du sud est
j'ai voyagé en stop les rencontres sont
un élément important de mon voyage
les gens qui m'héberge qui m'accueille
les routiers les chauffeurs qui met par
m kilomètre par kilomètre font
qu'aujourd'hui je suis là avec vous ces
gens là sont vraiment la locomotive de
mon voyage ils me permettent
d'économiser mon argent et de réaliser
ensemble des projets pour des
associations pour enfants il ya des
rencontres très particulière celle de
réunionnais rencontrés sur ma route pour
les rencontres et j'utilise internet
je crois en internet cet outil qui peut
et qui doit relier les hommes dans la
vie réelle c'est ce qui m'a permis de
rencontrer ces réunionnais grâce à des
sites comme réunionnais du monde
nous avons passé ensemble du temps nous
sommes raconter des histoires j'ai pu
m'imprégner leur quotidien de leurs
difficultés et ces gens là m'ont
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup appris par
exemple car elle championne de france
d'échecs qui s'est installé au cambodge
pour pouvoir justement c'est nier les
échecs aux enfants cambodgiens ou encore
emmanuel étudiante à pékin qui voyagent
également à travers le monde
guillaume journalistes le premier
réunionnais que j'ai rencontré en
arménie et les exemples sont nombreux
ces réunionnais sont vraiment un élément
important de mon voyage parce qu'il me
montre tout ce qu'il est possible qu'il
est possible que quelques quel que soit
l'endroit d'où l'on vient on peut
arriver tout en croyant en ses rêves
aujourd'hui grâce à leurs rêves ils ont
pu m'aider moi et j'ai pu à mon tour
grâce à aider d'autres enfants par mon
voyage
j'essaie aussi à mon niveau de démontrer
que par nature l'homme et bienveillant
aujourd'hui nous sommes inondés de
mauvaises nouvelles dans mon book
violence à la télé mais dès qu'on se met
sur la route on réalise que les gens
sont là pour vous aider ils le font avec
plaisir au départ de mon voyage j'avais
un sac de 15 kg j'avais mis en fait
toutes mes angoisses de pulls jeans une
grosse trousse de toilette une grosse
frousse en cas d'urgence les premiers
jours et des très très dur je m'étais
jamais posé la question de savoir en
fait
l'avim avait épargné sa de savoir où est
ce que j'allais pouvoir dormir qu'est ce
que j'allais pouvoir manger à qui
j'allais pouvoir faire confiance à qui
j'allais confier ma vie l'espace d'un
instant et très vite ces gens là ont
fait de ces angoisses un véritable
plaisir
je prends du plaisir aujourd'hui jour
après jour à me demander qui va me
prendre en stop quelle histoire cette
personne va avoir à me raconter à mon
tour je lui raconte aussi mes histoires
mes voyages mes rencontres j'ai un
dossier de voyages qui est de plus en
plus épais donc assez lourd maintenant
et qu'importe la langue
nous communiquons tous avec un sourire
avec des gestes
j'ai voulu également me rendre en iran
que j'ai traversé à vélo j'avais trouvé
un vélo pour aller rencontrer un
cycliste iranien mohamed hage rang il
passe sa vie
d'école en école avec son vélo à
enseigner aux enfants pourquoi tu il est
important aujourd'hui de prendre soin de
l'environnement
par ces rencontres par cette rencontre
avec mohamed j'ai voulu montrer que dans
des pays aujourd'hui avec lesquels on a
des images plutôt négativement il existe
aussi des personnes qui à leur niveau et
c'est de rendre ce monde meilleur
l'une des plus belles rencontres de ce
voyage est sans aucun doute la nature
j'ai passé des moments assez insolite
j'ai dormi dans des endroits assez
exceptionnel comme ici la grande
muraille ou encore là près d'un train
qui passait en fait un rail je pensais
qu'il était désaffecté est en pleine
nuit j'entends que youtube et c'est le
train qui arrivait comme ici au
kirghizstan que j'ai traversé à vélo un
pays extrêmement montagneux avec des
montagnes en moyenne situe à 3000 m
d'altitude et j'ai pris conscience de la
nature
avant je ne faisais que la croiser dans
un robinet au supermarché
cette nature-là de kilomètre en
kilomètre allait m'apporter de l'eau
l'eau dans la rivière des fruits que
j'allais cueillir également quand il n'y
avait pas de supermarché enfin n'y en a
pas quand il est pas de petites
boutiques où je pouvais pas me faire
héberger et je me suis juré que j'allais
à mon niveau
essayer de soulager cette planète qui
aujourd'hui souffrent alors à chaque
fois maintenant je vois
j'essaye une bouteille ou quelque chose
d'autre dans la rue je pense à combien
de temps cet objet va mettre à
disparaître
et je me rappelle en fait ces moments où
la nature m'a offert des moments
exceptionnels et je me dis bah en fait
que ça me prend que 30 secondes pour le
ramasser ça me permet aussi avec une
petite action d'aidé la nature qui elle
aussi n'a été alors bien sûr il n'y a
pas besoin de faire un grand voyage pour
voir qu'autour de nous aussi on a la
chance de vivre dans une nature
exceptionnelle cette photo a été prise
il ya quelques jours où gilbert pounia
pour la petite anecdote m'a est pris en
stop et m'avait déposé justement m'avait
dit m'a bien la maison et tout j'ai dit
non non je vais aller camper à la plaine
des cafres et cette photo illustre bien
en fait
aquaro centre certaines de minuit avant
j'avais la télé j'avais une console de
jeu plusieurs écrans aujourd'hui je
regarde le ciel le ciel est devenu ma
télé je regarde des satellites je
regarde des étoiles j'essaye d'y mettre
des formes et je prends conscience à
quel point il est important encore une
fois de respecter cette nature et grâce
à toutes ces rencontres
tous ces gens qui m'ont aidé nous avons
réussi nous avons essayé de contribuer
justement à des projets pour des
associations comme ici dans le
haut-karabakh avec cette petite fille on
a participé à permettre à 160 enfants
d'aller en colonie de vacances
entre le mois d'août et le mois de juin
dernier ou encore au kirghizstan grâce à
l'aide de tous les nomades qui m'ont
hébergé de construire des terrains de
jeu pour des enfants handicapés
mais ce n'est pas uniquement de l'argent
c'est aussi du temps le temps est mon
meilleur ami dans ce voyage n'est pas
d'itinéraire pas de date de retour fixe
et j'aime passer du temps avec les
enfants j'aime écouter leurs rêves et
j'aime leur transmettent ce que moi
j'aime ici par exemple au cambodge
j'ai animé un petit atelier avec des
enfants pour leur apprendre à faire des
photos
dans les prochains mois 1 je vais partir
pour l'himalaya à partir du mois de mars
dans une région qui s'appelle au dos le
pot à 5000 mètres d'altitude et je vais
réaliser là bas un petit documentaire
pour essayer d'informer justement sur
les enjeux auxquels l'himalaya est
confronté les enjeux environnementaux la
perte des traditions
j'aurais pu bien sûr avant ce voyage
m'offrir un billet pour arriver
directement comme sa part acheté dans
l'himalaya
mais je pense que dans la vie c'est pas
finalement l'himalaya ou l'endroit qu'on
soit atteinte qui est important c'est
comment on y va et ses dix mois de
voyages m'ont permis de me comprendre
mieux de comprendre mieux les gens qui
m'entourent et aujourd'hui c'est avec la
plus grande détermination que je ne
rends dans l'himalaya
je voudrais terminer en vous disant que
je suis vraiment content parce que j'ai
animé des petits ateliers avec les
enfants
je voulais vraiment intégré la réunion à
cette première partie de mon voyage et
parce que je présente la réunion dans
les pays dans lesquels je voyage et je
souhaitais exactement faire la même
chose ici à la réunion en présentant les
pays à des écoliers réunionnais et
certains d'entre eux m'ont fait un
énorme cadeau ils m'ont offert des
cartes postales de la réunion et m'ont
dit ben voila tu pourras les remettre
aux enfants de l'himalaya
la réunion est vraiment importante dans
mon voyage
nous avons cette chance exceptionnelle
ici sans avoir voyagé de connaître les
sons de l'inde
le goût de la chine les douleurs de
l'afrique l'art la réunion ne représente
que 0,0000 5% à superficie mondiale
ce n'est rien mais elle m'a permis de
réaliser que quel que soit l'endroit où
je me trouve dans le monde
elle n'est jamais très loin merci